It went so fast.
Bye.
Oh,
I don't know why so many people thought this was a collab.
Sorry to disappoint you.
I'm only playing a game.
Because people can't read.
Maybe.
Wow, real Korone on screen.
Oh, Korone-san, what do you have to say?
Welcome to my stream.
Oh.
Uh, she says...
She says...
Wow.
She says, wow, wow.
Just like the game.
Wow, wow, wow.
Such true words.
Yeah, she said that, for real.
Yeah.
I'm excited to play.
Look at this.
This is so cute.
Yubi!
Oh, one Yubi.
Yubi, Yubi!
Two Yubi.
Yubi, Yubi, Yubi.
Machine gun.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Shot the gun.
Bunk, bunk.
Bunk, bunk, bunk, hammer.
Wait, she says other things too.
And there's also other weapons to unlock.
I don't know why it looks like a sensor.
Bone?
Okay.
Okayu?
Cat?
I don't know.
Yubi Yubi!
Machine gun!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Shot gun.
Yeah.
So we're gonna, we're just gonna hang out and play for a
little bit.
Today's stream won't be super long because I have some stuff
that I need to get done.
I got a new thing to build.
A shelf.
I bought a shelf that I have to build.
And just some other things.
Ikea moment.
Yeah, basically.
Lemo, lemo!
Thank you for the tiny gift.
Thank you!
But I just wanted to still chill and hang out.
little bit today yeah and I thought this would be perfect so
we have a couple I've never played this before it was just
officially released like a couple days ago so I do want to
play holo cure cuz I really like I really like a vampire
survivor and stuff so
Um...
Mint, don't read.
But yeah, um, probably will try a holocure at some point
too.
We'll just do normal mode.
Let's go!
I'm a dog!
Oh, how do I move?
Oh.
Ah!
Is that a thing I've destroyed?
Actually, I'm not sure.
Wait, this way?
Oh, what's this?
Yumi!
Oh!
Ah!
Wait, what is this thing?
What is this thing?
Oh.
I'm dog.
Oh, there's a...
Oh, no!
Ah!
Oh, I like the shotgun, actually.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh!
Ah!
The Danmaku.
It's okay.
I've played Toho.
times.
Oh no.
This is already so fun.
Right click?
Wait, what's the difference?
Maybe normal mode is too easy.
I said that.
That I don't know.
Oh my god, the achievement is I've died.
Thank you forever.
My score is two?
That's it.
Let's go, amigo.
Let's go.
Oh, I have to get these.
Yubi, Yubi.
So do come.
Check the gut.
Oh, the guys come out of there.
I understand now.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
He's gonna explode.
Yubi!
Oh, I almost walked right into that guy.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, this way.
It's okay.
Again, I play Toho.
Oh, Bunk!
Wow!
Ha!
This one feels like you gotta get kind of close on them,
though, right?
Ooh.
Pro Mint Gaming, obviously.
This way.
Shut the gun!
The bonk is kind of dangerous.
Yeah, because you have to get real close
Collect five coronet boxes Okay, hold on I don't want to
like go through stuff so fast, but I also want to see the
other stages and stuff right Mr. Albeze, thanks for the 10
gift.
Thank you.
It's one hit KO One hit KO This one looks cute too.
That's crap.
Let's go sunshine, amigo!
Sunshine!
No!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Get out of my way.
Yubi, Yubi!
Yubi, everybody!
Oh my god, I'm stuck.
Bunk, bunk!
Not the bunk.
Also the bunk, you can't just endlessly shoot.
Sunshine Amigos!
This way?
Oh my god, thank you forever.
What?
I used the bonk, you guys all saw.
Let's go Sunshine Amigos!
Sunshine Amigos!
You beat Revolver!
My favorite.
Oh, wait.
Wait, I want to use it a little bit.
Where's the, where's the bat?
It bounces!
Wait, six shots.
I don't want to change it.
This king is scary.
Shotgun.
Retry.
Retry, retry, retry.
Retry, retry.
Yes.
Also, you can't go in the water.
Shotgun.
There we go.
Ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay.
Back off!
No
bonk!
How's everybody doing?
This weekend.
Oh my gosh.
No bonk.
Yubi yubi yubi.
Pretty good.
Wow!
Oh my god.
The revolver is powerful, you guys!
Right, I think the revolver is kind of the best.
No, no bonk!
No bonk!
Yubi Yubi!
Six shots.
Grocery shopping.
That's always important to do on the weekends, right?
X potato.
Oh!
I unlocked the X- Another working Sunday.
Happy to listen.
Oh, good luck!
Maybe this is...
This is like a harder game to listen to.
It's kind of noisy, right?
Let's go, amigo!
Let's go!
I like the stage though.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, this way.
Machine gun!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
It's shaky.
Oh!
What's the difference between right click and left click?
Yubi, yubi!
Yubi!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Ow!
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, and then the button.
One is right, the other is not.
You're so right.
I don't want to get rid of my UB revolver.
I know the shotgun is so powerful, but like...
The revolver is so awesome.
Nice, Sue.
We'll see you go.
You!
Yubi Yubi!
Yubi?
Yubi.
Everybody.
Oh yeah!
Just shoot everywhere, miss everything.
You die.
Thank you, Koiba.
Okay, let's try the next stage.
The orange box.
Yubi Yubi.
Just don't get hit.
Give up your Yubis for sacrifice.
You can't even see my UBs!
They're hidden!
They're hidden, my UBs.
Let's go sunshine, amigo!
Wait, this map is kind of... black.
Wait, I don't want to get the box before I...
Oh!
Whoa!
UB!
Seems kind of a waste to...
To get rid of it.
Did she just scream?
Oh my god, no, I don't like the road!
Take my Yubi.
Wait, who else is shooting?
Oh, those are me.
Bonk, bonk.
Oh no, no, no bonk, no bonk.
It's bonk too difficult, bonk too difficult!
Oh, this way, it is this way.
Run away, run away, run away!
Run away, run away!
This way.
Okay, this stage is so tricky!
Okay, nice.
I was- I'm doing
it!
Nice.
Yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy.
Oh my god, it's pushing me!
pushing me away.
Where's shotgun?
This way.
This way, this way.
I think we're good- hit this way.
How do I get there?
Shoe, shoe, shoe, shoe, shoe.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Ow!
I swear.
No!
No bonk, no bonk.
Where is she?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, no.
You have to get so close!
Please!
Ow!
I think I have to go this way.
Meow!
Oh, here we go.
Oh!
Joshi!
Oh my god.
Oh no no no no no!
Confidence!
There's even bosses!
Oh my gosh.
Level!
Thanks for the 20 gift.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
You can parry bullets.
You can!
No confidence.
Have confidence.
It's crazy because I did the best on this round.
Even though the stage was so crazy.
so crazy.
Oh, my contact is...
Let's go sunshine, amigos!
If only I had gotten the X potato cannon again.
Oh, uh...
Maybe it's kind of hard to use, too.
Nice!
Oh!
I'm... I think I am cheating the system.
What do I have right now?
Blubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbub.
Oh, down here.
There
we go.
Oh my gosh, that was so close.
AHAA!
I think I got...
Yeah, I'm stuck.
I'm just gonna keep shooting.
Ow!
There we go.
Oh, here it is.
Here it is.
Yubi, Yubi!
Am I hitting anything or am I hitting at nothing?
I'm hitting everything at nothing at the same time.
Juba!
Go!
Don't go with it!
When she laughs, it's so funny.
This guy's back.
We're at the box.
It's a good question.
He came from nowhere.
Spray and pray.
No, he came from nowhere.
No!
Okay.
Let's go sunshine, amigo!
Sunshine!
much more um energy when she says when she says amigos
actually i think i prefer shooting in like oh this way
shooting in like the one direction then both use using the
finger guns like this
uh here we go bunk bunk wait i want to test it oh you can
You can shoot the bullets back.
That's not...
Oh my god, the roaches are so fast.
Oops.
But you do have to be pretty close.
And it's also only... it's directional, so it's a little
tricky in that regard.
Yep!
Oh, that was so close.
That was so close.
Ice!
I hear them coming out.
Goodbye, little roach.
Oh my gosh!
X potato cannon is OP!
I don't want to get rid of it!
It's so awesome!
Ah, this side.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where is she?
Nice.
I think I killed some...
Everybody!
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
I'm sorry!
She literally took a...
Took a...
A cannon to the face.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Launched into orbit.
Ah!
Well, fuck!
Well, fuck, fuck.
Does it work for these?
Oh, it does.
But it's...
They're slow.
It's tricky.
Okay, oh, I need to go this way?
Where is it?
The three Husketeers?
Wait, where are they?
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Oh, yeah.
No!
I got knocked by dog.
I got it.
A listener sign needs to chill.
For real.
Chainsaw.
I'm glad you're enjoying your hell divers training.
I didn't even get to shoot the...
I didn't even get to see the boss at all.
Welcome, amigo.
Let's go.
This one, this stage is tricky, but I think I like it.
Nice job.
I like the challenge, you know?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, fuck.
Cute bastard.
Thank you for the 50.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you so much.
Wait, hold on.
What's going on?
Oh.
Making sure I don't have a phone call.
Oh, no, we're good.
Okay, my phone was, like, going crazy for some reason.
I was like, you're streaming!
You're supposed to be streaming!
Dang!
Is it on camera?
If you can use it correctly, it's pretty good, actually.
It's actually pretty good.
So, do I got that
one.
Did it count?
I don't like the roach.
Uh...
I'm a dog!
Also, please don't send me super chats about my taxes.
Thank you.
I think that's...
Oh!
Oh...
Okay.
She said I have confidence, you guys.
We got this.
Next, potato!
Now I'm very confident with my...
weapon.
Oh, no!
That was really bad.
At least there's no...
At least there's no backsplash.
No confidence, you guys.
No confidence.
It's the...
It's the rouches.
Not.
Oh, gosh.
Let's get her.
Let's get her now.
Maybe we got her.
I don't know.
There we go.
Okay.
This way.
How am I making so many?!
Okay, let's choose...
Let's go back to this one.
I like the pepper box.
Hard mode.
Let's go sunshine, amigo!
Sunshine!
How hard can it be?
How hard can it be, you guys?
I haven't been able to do a single boss, but how hard can it
be?
Bunk!
Bunk, bunk!
Machine guy!
The thing
about this game makes me want to like...
Oh my gosh.
It makes me want to like conserve bullets even though I know
that's not a thing.
You know what I mean?
Oh, oh, we got him!
Oh, she's back!
Where is it?
Oh, this way.
Oh my gosh, wait.
I think hard mode is kind of in...
It's like...
It's actual Toho now.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
It's actual Toho now.
Ah!
No!
Oh, my God.
Live!
The machine gun sucks.
It pushes you into all the...
Into everything.
It pushes you into everything.
No!
Leave, leave, leave, leave.
Go away.
Go, listen.
Oh, no.
Ow, no, no!
Ow, yo, yo!
Ow!
Ah!
I got my same scores before.
This is Toho.
Ah!
My one contact is so...
Make my eyes so dry!
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
I think we're good.
We try.
Oh!
We get to try the chainsaw.
I don't think the chainsaw is the weapon for me, everybody.
I don't think the chainsaw...
I'm dying, thank you for...
Or maybe any
weapon...
Maybe I'm... skill issue...
Skill issue, something, something.
Fuck!
Fuck, fuck, fuck!
Get good, something, something...
Wait, am I on hard mode?
again or am i actually i don't remember did it no no
chainsaw no i don't like chainsaw oh oh the what's it called
for that is the splash damage is good but the reload time is
not good
skillish I
got no confidence game over without collecting a single
Corone box.
Let's go.
He spawn camped me.
Real.
He spawned camped me in real.
Where'd that dog go?
I don't like the chainsaw.
Get me out of here.
Bunk, bunk, bunk, bunk.
No bunk either!
Roach!
Invasion!
Mint is back, I'm so happy!
Thanks for the super chat!
Thank you!
Get
away from me, roach!
Get away from me, roach!
And everything!
And nothing!
We
beat my last score now.
Josie!
Oh, ow!
Those guys were just coming up on me so fast.
I can't even see the bosses.
Wait, did I...
I am playing it on hard mode.
Okay, normal mode.
Normal mode.
I gotta build up my...
my power level.
I wish there was an in-between though.
I feel like maybe the normal mode...
Not that it's so easy, but...
I think I'm just making silly mistakes, you know what I
mean?
Is this way?
There we go.
Okay, this way.
Oh.
Potato...
Come in, thank you!
Wow, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh my gosh, so many roaches!
Thank you, potato!
Ah!
Welcome!
I felt like a little bit like a homing...
Like a homing, uh, Danmaku.
Oh, I'm not good at the...
Oh my gosh.
Why does this feel more difficult than the hard mode?
But...
Bunk!
No bunk!
I'm not good at the directional with the bunk hammer.
Yumi Yumi!
Yumi!
Oh!
We're already here!
Where is he?
Ow!
Oh, there he is!
Ah!
Oh, I've died!
Please, I just want to fight the boys!
What a way to die.
It was so stupid.
It was actually so dumb.
It was actually so stupid.
I don't like the machine gun because it pushes you into,
like, other...
To other Damaku.
What?
There we go.
Yeah, get his butt.
Get that guy's butt.
Yeah, get his butt, get his butt, get his...
But I'm trying to go this way.
Yes, no!
A shot of gun!
Hey, okay.
Oh, I'm done.
Thank you, forever.
I...
You're such a pro gamer, VTuber.
Thanks.
My high score?
11.
What's your high score?
200?
Pro gamer 11 high score You know, I'm just a huge stranger
things fan, you know Can't really blame me for that.
It's just you know I'm just keeping up with the Cool
stranger things lore You know
Thank you so much for the 50!
Oh.
I shouldn't waste these.
Oh, gosh.
Bye, dog.
Yumi, Yumi.
Oh, my God.
Not the roaches, please.
Not the roaches.
Why are they so fast?
Also, wait.
Does this cut through?
Oh, it does.
Oh.
That's kind of nice.
Doesn't help if they're coming from behind.
I don't know what my favorite weapon is yet.
Oh, oh wait, should that?
That's okay?
No, not nice!
Not nice!
Hand mine.
Wait, how many more weapons do we have?
I was so close to getting the boss again.
Yuppie, yuppie, yuppie, yuppie.
Machine gun, shotgun.
Chain zone!
Nice!
Hopped in to say hi.
Hello!
Things are dapping back.
Oh, there's still quite a lot actually that we haven't
unlocked.
Let's go.
Let's go back to this one actually.
Let's try that.
Have confidence.
Okay.
She said...
Eggs, potato.
Bunk.
Bunk, bunk, bunk.
Bunk, bunk.
Bunk.
Wait, is it this way?
Nope.
Hmm...
Oh!
Have a confidence, everybody.
Shoot nothing!
Hit everything!
I always lose or miss the chainsaw!
Oh gosh, please!
Please!
Okay, I'll take the bonk, I'll take the bonk!
Just gotta get through here.
Here we go!
Oh, I still don't...
I don't know how this one works wait i'm just gonna leave it
oh you will wait what do i oh the
dog's gonna come move eventually detonate
wait actually sometimes
it's just bad rng sometimes it's mean
you'll be you'll be you'll be you'll be
Listener, son.
Oh, no!
It's a human time.
I love the...
Oh, it's the ping.
Yeah, it's the ping.
Uh, something, something playing through OBS.
Not really.
That's my favorite opener.
Where's the box?
Oh, oh, all the way down there?
It's always these guys.
They rush you!
They actually rush.
They come in full of confidence.
Oh no no no no no no no no no no no!
Okay, I'm
gonna die.
I'm from the chainsaw!
It doesn't seem like it's a bad weapon.
It's just I think I don't know how to properly use it so
well.
See like there is pretty good.
You don't need to judge with the chainsaw.
That was so unlucky.
It was so fast right out of there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The chainsaw killing bullets is really good.
It is really good.
Are there achievements?
There are steam achievements.
Yeah.
Let's go sunshine, amigo.
Sunshine.
I've been getting some of them.
Like, collect 200 Korone boxes.
Stuff like that.
I thought it would kill him in one hit.
I was wrong.
It's okay.
They can stay over there in their little corner.
Get me out of here.
Not the machine gun.
No, machine gun.
I don't like the machine gun.
I have to go back a little bit.
when I use it.
I feel like the machine gun is the worst one.
It's very hard to use.
It's very, it's very hard to use.
Oh my god, there should be a leaderboard.
I'd be top.
Mint Phantom.
Number one.
You'll be collector.
Sorry.
Oh.
Nice!
They charge once they see you.
Can the bullets like...
Just trying to get this dope.
This stage is really hard for the cannon also.
Oh, no, I tried to aim up.
There we go.
Are you trying to kill me?
No, I'm trying to go this way.
Please.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
Ow!
There we go.
Okay, we got, we're getting rid of a few of them at least.
Let's go around.
Okay.
If I can get one more box, we can go against the box.
Watch?
Are
you kidding?
It's always the roaches.
Oh my gosh.
You keep jinxing it?
I know.
I'll never get past 11.
Have confidence.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, she's so awesome.
She says have confidence.
Get past 11.
Oh, roach bad.
True.
Wait.
Right here.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Not the hand mine.
Wait, can it...
Oh, it does explode.
Oh, I got the bonk anyway.
Oh my gosh.
Shuba, please.
Got him before he could come for me.
I could support.
Die!
Totally.
Nice aim, thank you.
Change the wall!
Okay, to explain, I was trying to hit, like, maybe a wall or
something to explode as many as possible.
But it just wasn't happening.
Who is sending so many?
Nice.
Of the wall.
Come here, you.
We got him before.
Before.
Guys, I think she might like the revolver a lot.
No, it's okay.
The explosions from the X potato destroys bullets, too,
right?
Yes, it seems to be the case.
That seems to be the case.
Revolver is fine.
It's not like...
But it's okay.
It's not bad.
It's never really...
Is there like a...
Is this a dead end?
Oh my gosh.
It is.
Yeah, there's not really a good reason to come down here.
Oh my gosh.
Unless I want to die by Roach!
No, please!
Oh god!
I don't like the Roach.
I don't like the Roach!
No Roach!
Oh my gosh, please.
Why does it feel like it picks up so much around 5?
Oh my god, please.
Okay, there we go.
Bunk, bunk.
Bunk has too hard, too long of a cooldown, I feel like.
Oh my god, no, no, no, no, no.
He's too...
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, you're crazy.
I was doing so well, but also getting nothing.
Roaches are so crazy.
Am I getting worse?
Maybe.
Who knows?
That was the most intense gaming I've ever seen.
I don't think I was getting worse.
It was just really hard to get around from there.
I think I was getting bad RNG weapons.
Because the X can- the potato cannon is great but does not
help in this level.
Oh my gosh.
Does not help at all.
Chainsaw.
Wow.
Oh, okay.
This is- this works.
Uh, open here.
Ah!
Okay, nice.
Uh, this way.
Okay.
Hi, okay.
Yumi, yumi, yumi, yumi, yumi, yumi, yumi, yumi, yumi, yumi.
Tara's gonna hear this and she's gonna...
You know what?
Good.
Let her hear it.
I'm destroying her precious...
I'm not
even...
It's a pathetic way to die ever.
You did that all to yourself.
I did.
It's always 11.
I know I got a hit in.
I got a hit in.
Let's go sunshine, amigo.
Sunshine!
If
I put one down and then another.
Oh, interesting.
So I should just start putting them down everywhere.
Yubi Yubi!
Oh, I can shoot now.
I can shoot now.
Tain soul.
Yubi Yubi!
Bunk, bunk, bunk, bunk.
This is it.
Back this way, back this way, back this way.
Yeah!
Hit everything and nothing!
Hit everything and...
Oh, that was close, that was close, that was close.
No, no, no, no, not machine gun, not machine gun.
Please no, please no, not machine gun, not machine gun.
Nice.
Sorry.
I shouldn't, I shouldn't, um, maybe...
Are you kidding me?
Um...
There's no way!
There's no way I could have fought the boss with...
With the hand mines!
There's no way!
That RNG was so bad.
Ah!
Worst weapon for the boss!
That was so bad!
We got there so quickly too!
Ah!
I'm a ghost!
Bunk, bunk!
Sorry, man.
It's okay.
I'm having
fun.
Oh, this way.
That's part of the game, you know?
Is you just, uh...
Try and try and try and try and try again.
It's one of those fast-paced games, you know?
Wait, wait.
Oh, it's this way.
Oh my god, no, no, no, no!
Nice.
Okay.
Whew, that was close.
That was a close one.
It can kind of help launch you where you need to go.
But also, it's not...
Not easy.
Oh, shoot.
We're so close.
It's very addictive for sure.
Quick reset is a lot of fun.
Yeah, yeah, for sure.
Yeah, for sure.
The curse is broken.
You didn't get 11 this time.
Let's go sunshine!
Yeah we got worse!
We didn't get 11, we got worse!
Listener sign.
Putting you out of your misery.
We're gonna...
Oh my gosh.
Shotgun.
Yubi Yubi!
Oh, that one.
Let's hit him.
Not nice.
I need to go.
I'm learning more how to control this.
I'm learning more how to control it, I think.
So, to go.
Shuba sniped.
No confidence.
You're never going to beat a boss.
We will.
The stream will end until we beat a boss.
Actually, I am going to switch to...
We got to unlock a new weapon.
Let's switch to this place.
I think this one is easier for the cannon.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Aqua super day.
Yubby, yubby.
Sometimes, I'll be honest.
arrow pointing towards the...
Pointing towards the next box makes me feel like that's
where I'm pointing at.
So if you think I'm...
If you see me making a mistake like that, that's exactly
what I'm thinking.
I'm looking at the arrow as if it's where I'm pointing my
weapon you know.
Because my brain is silly.
Maybe this map isn't as good!
Maybe this map is really difficult!
11 seems to be your lucky number.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you for the 11-11.
Oh my gosh.
Everyone play the lottery?
Play the lottery?
Use 11.
Should I say Dunkin' Pong?
Does this also get rid of the, uh...
Does this also get rid of the missing gun?
The bullets?
Oh my god, no, no!
Ah!
Yeah!
It's just a gun!
Uh, this way.
I did not shoot.
Let's go, amigo!
Let's go!
Listener, son, please.
Why would you treat your Oshi like this?
They know I'm a phony.
Maybe this one is actually more difficult because it's a
little bit more open.
Hug me!
Get out of my way!
Power, please!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Not exactly what I was thinking, but...
It will maybe do the trick.
Oh, I don't think I got...
It's a dog!
Why are you so fast?
The circle!
Could be worse.
Could be way worse.
The dogs just run through...
Oh my god.
The dogs just run through the chainsaw.
It's crazy.
I'm so concentrated right now, you guys.
You have no idea.
Why?
Why Banca?
Okay, where's the... Where's the...
Where's the guy?
Oh, you think he's down here.
This is not easy.
Um...
Then we hide behind the trees.
Wait, I can also bonk these back, right?
I should have bonked them and bonked the back.
At least you can deflect the bullets or not.
Come on, Korane.
We got this.
She's like, I've got this.
You!
On the other hand...
That is questionable, whether you've got this or...
Oh, nice!
Get mined.
Oh, God.
Yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
I didn't see you there!
Oh, whoa, whoa!
Shotgun.
Uh, next one down here.
Where?
Here?
I like the hand mine actually.
It has a slow...
Oh!
It has a slow recharge but I like being able to control it
too.
Let's go Sunshine Amigo.
I got a Frisbee!
Let's go Amigo!
Wait, we unlocked something else!
Wait.
Yubi Yubi!
Let's see if we get it.
Frisbee!
Whack!
Bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk.
Oh,
she says jankin because it's the hand.
That's cute.
Oh, that saved me.
That saved me for real.
I like that the mines also stay.
They stay too, which is nice.
So I can set them up everywhere and then...
Wait, just...
Oh, oh, yeah!
Does it... Okay, we also can do those.
Maybe if I just loop these...
Okay, nice.
Good job, guys!
We did it!
No!
You can die by the frisbee.
That's how I died.
I got an achievement called Get hit by the frisbee.
A bone meringue.
The frisbee sucks.
You can also right click to reflect it.
Oh!
Still congratulations, man.
Thank you.
Yippee!
Thank you for the five-gifted ducky.
Thank you.
I was sending them out like crazy, too.
Okay, though.
That's not fair.
If you can't get hit by the revolver's bullets...
I'm a duck!
You shouldn't be able to get hit by the frisbee either.
Oh my god.
Not already.
Get out of my face.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
I want to try the frisbee.
Here it is.
But I do want to try it also.
I think I got him this time.
That was close.
That was a close one.
Please!
They're so aggressive!
They're so aggressive.
Ah, my aim.
I'm hoping, I'm like spraying a little bit and praying that
the splash damage gets them.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my
god, oh my god, oh my god!
No, I'm just, I'm just placing them down.
Change the wall!
For Joshi.
Okay, this is the guy we did before.
Go away, roaches!
Go away!
Wait, if I just do this...
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
If I just do this, it's not so bad, right?
Actually.
It's actually kind of awesome.
Oh,
okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Do I get it back, or...
A bl-bl-bl-bl-bl-
so close.
Starting to believe.
Ah!
Right click for three.
at once.
Oh, I keep forgetting to right click on these weapons.
Like I do it on this one because it...
Instead of like doing the side by side you do the one
direction.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no.
Bunk, bunk, bunk, bunk, bunk.
I'll take a bunk, I'll take a bunk.
Recharge.
So I'm not sure how...
Hmm.
YARUHODO YARUHODO What if I right click on this one?
Is it the same?
Can't tell actually.
I inhaled so fast that I choked on my spit.
Don't die, I'm already dead!
Dang, these are all like right next to it!
We're already at 6.
I don't even need to...
Machine
gun.
Machine gun.
Oh my god.
Oh, okay.
No, Shuba, please.
Shuba.
How am I supposed to beat him with the hammer?
Yeah!
Lower him.
I didn't even get a single hit on it.
Oh, there.
Let's go.
Lower him.
Let's go sunshine, amigo.
Sunshine.
Back to 11.
Okay.
11 curse.
Game is tricky though.
It's fun, but it's...
Also me bad.
But that's okay.
I
like the hand mine.
It's just not good for stuff quick or for...
Yeah, situations where you need to be firing a lot and fast.
Wait, oh, it's this way.
Why am I going?
Why am I going down?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ah,
stop.
Okay.
Just a wall!
Die.
Please bounce.
Yay, yay, yay, yay, yay.
Listener, son.
So small and so easy to miss.
Oh!
Where is it?
Oh, this way.
Okay.
What the?
What is this?
Pinky pledge.
No confidence.
The terror.
I don't like bugs.
I hate that one so much.
Ah!
Yeah, I didn't know what that one did, so I was just running
to see if...
Okay, that's okay.
That's okay.
It's like race and spell card.
Not the actual Toho.
I haven't played in Perishable Night.
I don't even know.
Actually, I'll be honest, I probably have played in
Perishable Night.
The least.
This wasn't one of my favorites.
Which is okay.
I don't know what the...
It's hard to say, or it's hard for me to figure out what
the...
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
How big the splash damage is on the mines.
There we go.
Take that guy out real fast!
Shut the gun!
Terraceable Knight is peak.
It's good, it's just not one of my favorites.
I played, um, Mountain of Faith, Must, and, uh, Hello?
Hello?
Perishable Night, and, uh...
Oh, no, no.
Oh my god!
How did I live?
How am I alive?!
Well, there was one other one.
I played UFO quite a bit.
Let's go, sunshine!
Um...
Sunshine!
Okay, um...
And, uh...
No frisbee, no frisbee, no frisbee, no frisbee!
No frisbee!
Oh god, I'm scared of the frisbee!
I'm scared of the frisbee!
There's gotta get me!
There's one that I'm...
Cannot...
Get me!
I don't know why I can't think of which one.
My brain is only consumed by Yubi.
I'm Yubi.
brain right now.
The overkill.
You know it's not overkill.
These guys are annoying.
These guys, these tiny little guys are pain in my side.
Pain in my side.
Oh my god.
Hello?
No, Shuba.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shuba now!
I just hear her go Shuba, Shuba, Shuba.
I'm trying to take some of these other guys out.
Oh my god.
Shuba, Shuba, Shuba, Shuba!
Maybe in like here.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, nice.
Nice, nice.
Take him out.
Oh, nope, never mind.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Whoa!
Oh my god.
That was a close one.
Oh!
Oh my god.
I'm in danger!
I'm in danger, you guys!
I'm in danger, I'm in danger.
Help me!
Help!
Nice!
Oh my god.
Screw you!
Little Rouch!
Sorry, dog.
Oh my god, that did not kill dog.
That did not finish off the dog.
Well, let Shuba do her thing over there.
Where is... Oh my god.
Oh my god, there's so many people!
Please, I'm an introvert!
I don't want to talk to anyone!
Okay, okay, okay.
Too real.
I only count up to 14, you guys.
This is intense.
I don't think, you know what, I intended on this being a
short stream anyway, because I just wanted to, you know,
hang out a little bit today, but I don't think I can
physically handle the amount of stress this game gives me.
For so long.
Keep
playing.
Next scene, thank you for the 50, thank you.
No, we're still gonna go!
I'm not done yet.
I'm having fun.
It's just terrifying.
It's a fun terrifying, right?
I'm scared.
And also...
Like these guys!
Oh!
I ran right
into it.
Oh!
Why am I so bad in this game?
No!
No confidence.
Oh!
What go...
What?
I saw someone say they got a score of 30.
I'm happy.
Halfway there, almost.
I'm almost halfway there.
Hello?
It's a dog.
That was scary.
This way.
Oh wait.
There we go.
I got 30 and unlock the neon cannons.
What's that?
Wait.
I want a cat.
What's that?
What's it do?
this is just definitely something I can see myself like
playing and you know I'm like oh I have a well I was gonna
say when I have a free extra a couple of minutes that's
quite rare but frisbee please frisbee it'd be fine if the if
the dog chased after the frisbee
Can you move?
No!
I needed to get to the box!
Where is it?
Stop chasing after my...
Why are you so obsessed with me?
There we go.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Oh, ha!
Defense!
That was absolutely 100% me.
That was 100% Me being greedy.
What's wrong with me?
Why did I do that?
That was me being greedy.
My greed.
Don't be greedy.
Oh my gosh.
Me Ling told me.
Let's go sunshine, amigo.
Sunshine.
Okay, I'm gonna pretend you guys aren't here.
Okay, sorry.
I'm gonna pretend you guys don't even exist.
Concentration.
I didn't see it.
I didn't see it!
Ah, dang it.
Ah, it's okay though.
Forever 19!
Woohoo!
Ah, you're pretty good.
Just blame it on us.
Say you peaked.
Okay.
I missed you guys a little bit, you know.
So I just, you know, had to make sure you were okay.
You were locked in there for a minute.
There were some parts that I got really lucky.
There's some parts though that I got really lucky that I
shouldn't have won, I think.
Nice focus run.
Thank you.
See, if I pretend I'm not streaming, it's a little...
See, I can't do alright.
I can do a little bit better.
See, performance anxiety is a real thing.
It was great watching your faces.
You got certain weapons ready.
Wakari, welcome to Membushib.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
My left contact.
I mean, my right contact.
Ah.
It's so...
I've been up so weird today.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I don't know what's up with.
it.
We haven't done the first stage in a while.
I will go back to it after this round.
Though I do think this is my favorite.
It's not the easiest, but I like it.
Chinsu!
Hello?
Oh, that was good timing.
wear glasses ever.
I absolutely hate glasses on me.
Especially because, um, wearing them with, uh, headset, um,
it digs into my ears and gives me really bad headaches.
So, I don't wear them.
Oh, that was fast.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I shot myself into the dog.
I shot myself into the dog.
Yeah.
I started wearing earbuds for that reason.
Yeah, yeah, it makes sense, right?
I like the look of them, but they are so annoying to wear.
Yeah, I like the look of them.
Well, actually, I don't really particularly like how they
look on me.
I like how they look on other people.
Or maybe that...
Oh, wait, sorry, I forgot to go to the other stage.
Maybe that's just me...
Like, what's the word?
Uh, trying to make it so I don't like them so that I don't
want to wear them.
You know what I mean?
Oh, that was up.
Why am I so silly?
Bye-bye!
Get out of here.
Oh!
That was...
Oh, my gosh.
That was so stupid lucky.
Shabbat!
Okay, I can leave.
Oops.
Bunk, bunk.
No frisbee.
Bunk!
Okay.
So do come!
Maybe...
Oh, not the worst for...
Where is he?
Oh!
Ha!
Oh my
god, not the roaches, please!
Not the roaches!
Go away!
away i can't get the roaches where's where are they where's
the pinky monster where's the pinky monster there there we
go man i jinxed it she's getting good stop what do you mean
What do you mean?
Yeah, you didn't fix it, though.
It's always...
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, God, my contact.
It's like...
I think it's just dry.
Oh!
Oops, I forgot to change those.
Um...
That's because I'm not blinking.
My...
Oh, why did I almost...
that guy like i thought he was a box that would have been
crazy i just walked into that guy like i thought he was a
box keep
placing them around um where they spawn
hydration check yes i will hydrate
Oh, Joshi again.
That's okay, because we were gonna do this anyway.
Red box.
I hear him.
Where are you?
Yumi, Yumi!
It's weird not being used to this stage!
Oh my god, please.
Oh, I have an itch.
Don't spawn.
Okay, thank you.
That also requires me to...
Oh my god!
Be...
Oh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
There's so many people!
An extrovert is what I was trying to say.
Do you hear that?
You hear that?
The box is...
Oh my god.
Why does the stage feel the most crowded as possible?
And those guys are so fast.
Pinky again!
Oh, oh my god.
Oh my god.
That was...
Whoa!
How am I alive?
Actually, I have no idea how I'm alive right now.
I should have died.
I should have died, I should have died, I should have died,
I should have died, I should have died, I should have died.
What is my hitbox anyway?
What even is my hitbox?
How did I hit it?
Very tiny.
It clearly is very tiny.
If I press shift, will I see it?
That wasn't maybe the best weapon.
Well, it was good, but also...
Not so easy for me.
I hate Frisbee.
No Frisbee.
Yeah, it's not great for bosses.
Yeah, that's for sure.
This is because it's weak.
Hard to find them.
Oh, oh, this way.
Also, I'm not familiar with this map.
Where is the box?
Oh, no, no,
no!
Um, this is...
Leave
me alone.
Oh, oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh!
Ah!
Oh, am I able to bomb?
Oh!
Okay, this way.
Really?
I don't want to fight the boss with the mind, though.
No confidence.
What if we get to the bot?
What if we get to the boss on hard?
Oh, wait, we did.
We did.
Okay, we can do it again.
We can do it again.
Go.
I believe.
I don't believe.
My gosh, girls.
I'm running up on me!
Oh, I forgot we're in hard mode.
I was like, why are there so many people already?
Oh, I'm done.
It's a lack of confidence thing, everybody.
It's a confidence thing, everybody.
I forgot we were on hard mode.
Oh, wow, they shoot so many more, too.
I just realized.
So I think everyone's faster and also...
They shoot more.
Yeah, this guy shoots way better.
Oh!
Wait, what did I hit?
I actually didn't notice at all.
Thank you, bye!
Thank you for the five!
Thank you!
What did I hit?
Revolver, Corroselot.
It was a fast bullet.
Oh, it was a bullet.
I thought I could.
Okay.
Wow.
I'm regressing?
Let's go, amigo!
For real.
Once again, the revolver seems to be a winner.
The revolver seems to be a real winner in this game.
I think it's actually super good.
Okay, I know this is going to sound like cope, but I pressed
D and I didn't.
Wait, I know this is going to sound like cope, but it was
actually my keyboard.
I know it sounds like cope for real.
But it was actually my keyboard!
Sure!
No!
It was!
It sounds like cope!
But I...
You know, you guys know that I'm the first to admit when I'm
actually bad at something.
You guys know I wouldn't cope like that!
You guys know!
Oh!
Ah, this way...
No machine gun.
Oh, good.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Yubby!
He's Josie again.
Those guys are really fast.
These ones, these ones.
I have to watch out for those.
Where is he?
Oh!
Oh my god!
Um, I think you are, it's like...
Sounds like rhymes with hope.
I've only known you for a week or two, Mint, so go.
You know what?
That's so fair.
Wow!
Me now, because it's the boss, you guys.
The 11 is the boss.
11 is the boss!
Alright.
Let's go, amigo!
Let's go!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
One more try.
Last.
LG, LG, everybody.
LG, LG, LG.
LG, LG.
Oh, I'm not.
No, hold on.
Hold on.
LG, one more time.
It's because...
Like, I know I ran into it.
The, um...
I forget that the chainsaw also pushes you.
Just like how the, uh, machine gun does.
Oh, I've died.
Thank you, forever.
LG, round three!
Let's go!
When I say LG, I mean, um...
One more try getting to the boss.
Oh my god, already.
Okay.
Why am I not shooting?
What's wrong with me?
Maybe I'm already checked out.
Maybe I'm like, you know what?
I'm done with this game.
I don't want to play with you anymore.
My roach trauma.
Wait, actually?
Oh, no.
Wait.
Oh, is this way?
Okay, that's new.
Okay, that's...
I didn't know.
Did it ever do that?
No, it didn't.
That's hard mode, baby.
TV table chair.
Thank you for the day.
I'm sorry.
I feel like I've just been screaming this whole time.
You know what?
Maybe we'll call it here.
Give my throat a rest.
No.
No, I don't feel satisfied.
I won't feel satisfied.
Try to walk.
Never mind.
LG.
LG again.
I wish I could just have the revolver the whole time.
Machine gun.
Oh, shooting
backwards!
Oh, this way.
Oh my god, they're all here.
Go away!
Go away, go away, go away.
Let me...
Okay.
Bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk.
Bonk, bonk, bonk.
lose to this little listener's hat, I might actually become
the Joker!
I was moving up, but I was too slow, I did it all right.
Ah!
The dark?
No, no, no.
It was if I died to the little guy, but I was fine.
Instead, I... I was moving up, but the...
I don't know.
I don't... I don't know.
What?
I mean, I guess obviously you hit my hitbox, but...
Hmm.
This stream could have its own scream compilation.
I'm the Joker.
Then keep going.
All it takes is one bad day.
Did you guys see the trailer for the next Joker movie?
The one with, uh...
Hold on, I'm fixing my contact again.
Oh, my eye hurt so bad.
Um...
with uh yeah with harley quinn lady gaga harley quinn i
usually avoid trailers that's that makes that no i i get
that i get that yeah oh it's out oh wait wait is it actually
out the frisbee killing you is a reference to the original
game super crate box that this game plays homage to from
2010 where the disc gun could bounce back and kill you ah
that makes Does that make sense?
Joker 2 with Joaquin and Lady Gaga.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
We live in a musical.
Yeah, Lady Gaga is playing Harley Quinn.
It actually looks so good.
Oh, it isn't out until October.
Who said that they saw it?
Everyone knows it's only LG if it's a good round.
Andragos, thanks for the time.
Gifted.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
don't care for the casting it's I think it's hold on I think
it's different yes like I wouldn't expect Harley Quinn to be
Lady Gaga but I don't think I mind it so much either me when
I spread misinformation I'm spreading misinformation on the
internet that's me when I spread misinformation I think I'll
still see it though I really like the first one lady Gaga
was great in American horror story so I'll reserve judgment
I think I tend to like lady Gaga a lot because people tend
to underestimate her like back in the day before she was
like like not back in the day like when she was still like
pop-up a poker face kind of lady gaga like people you know
just thought she was some generic pop star like singer and
that her singing was you know average but i can't believe
shrek came out 27 years ago no it didn't
have no idea one
shouldn't forget that overconfidence is a slow and insidious
killer stop calling me out i say the stream labs sorry that
i haven't been renting them out i see them though have
confidence minto chan minto chan kawaii totally real
undoctored kodone quote um
but yeah before when she was when lady gauga was still like
poker face lady people didn't know that she could sing but
She can sing so well, actually.
She's...
She's good.
Wait!
Oh, I'm on hard mode again, I forgot.
No, Frisbee!
Scared of Frisbee.
Don't do
that, mister.
Don't do that, mister.
I think this game has proven to me that my throat is never
going to recover.
I'm always going to be raspy for the rest of my life.
I think I'm always going to sound raspy for the rest of my
life.
Every time she says that...
It makes me think, It makes me think, Which is, you know,
like...
It reminds me of Freerun being in the mimic mouth.
Oh, I haven't gotten this in a while.
Oh my gosh.
Overkill, but that's okay.
Yumi, Yumi!
Yumi!
That's me in this game.
Kawaiyo!
I'm scared.
Does it sound like it?
Bunk, Bunk!
Bunk!
Soft go!
Shut the go- Okay, here we go.
What weapon are we gonna get for the boss?
Oh my god, don't jinx it!
Don't jinx it!
I'm dying, thank you forever.
And...
That was...
That was your classic jinx, everybody.
That was, like, the most classic jinx ever.
Let's go.
Thank you, Chiron-cha!
Thank you!
It
was down here, anyway.
Please.
I'm getting- I'm getting- I'm getting- I was getting
cornered.
Her duets with Bennett really showed her talent.
Who's Bennett?
Let's this way.
Run!
This way.
I'm regressing.
Who's Tony Bennett?
The singer?
What has he...
Um...
What has he done?
Okay, this is actual LG.
LG!
Oh.
Nice.
LG, everybody.
Oh my god.
Unless I get eaten by the roaches.
I don't know.
Where have you been, Shuba?
You were gone?
And then you came back?
And now...
Ugh!
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck!
No Frisbee!
No Frisbee.
Go away Frisbee.
Um...
Guys, I think I'm dead.
I think I'm dead.
Or not!
Oh my god.
How I lived that?
I don't know.
I don't know how I lived that.
Godgamer.
Don't clip any of my failures of just running into...
You know, normal guy.
Clip that one!
Clip me being a god gamer, okay everyone?
You know what?
That's okay.
Don't clip that part, because running into a small guy.
I didn't think it was possible for ghosts to be possessed,
but I think I was possessed by ninja.
Terrible.
Oh, don't clip this is not here.
No, no, no, no.
Oh.
Don't, don't, don't, don't there.
Don't, don't clip this.
Wait, wait, wait.
Hold on.
Actually, hold on.
Let's see.
Okay, hold on.
Now we just need it in...
Put it in black and I gotta find a font.
It's kind of similar.
Okay, hold on.
Let's see.
I know I have some.
Quick, someone contact the devs and ask them what font they
use.
I'll download it.
Do I not have...
8-bitty kind of font?
Oh,
I thought I had some.
I know I used to have some Maybe I have to re-download them
No The
one looks size Are you sure?
Are you sure?
I'm hacking I'm hacking The game right now What is that
What?
I don't remember ever downloading that.
What is this one?
Oh no, it's gone!
Uh-oh, I think I- I think I messed up.
Oh, wait.
It's so thin.
She's such a skilled gamer.
You guys, um, I'm gonna have to ask you to avert your eyes.
Because, um, I'm not- Trying to give away my gaming secrets
here right now, okay?
I'm just saying.
Okay.
What do you mean by that?
Ghost orb?
God gamer.
Literally just screen cap and crop.
Oh my gosh, you're so right, you're so right!
You're so right, you're so right, you're so right!
Why did I think of that?
Drum roll, please!
No, no, I promise you, Deb, I got 19!
I got 19!
That's my... I promise.
Right?
Right, chat, you can vouch for me.
You saw that.
Right, chat?
Chat, I'm grabbing you by your collar right now.
If you don't say that I didn't get 19, you better say that I
got 19 right now.
Is that the IQ?
You better tell, you better say, you got 19 and it was
really good run.
You better say that.
It's true, I saw 19.
19.
You got 19.
Thank you.
She's an 11, but she's a ghost.
Harder.
Yeah, you know what?
I do think we need a harder level.
I think you're right.
I think I need to be knocked down a peg.
I think I need to only get 5.
11 is too high for me
Can you grab me by the neck again?
No, I grabbed your collar Like a bully, you know?
It's true.
I was the 19th.
You know what?
It's not about quantity.
It's about quality, right?
You don't want to have...
You don't want to have 19, whatever friends.
You want to have 11 best friends you don't want to have 19
friends that you can't rely on 11 is the perfect number of
friends to have then the 11 best people exactly aim for 11
there I say the consistency to get this score I give it an
11 out of 10 thank you thank you very much thank you thank
you useless fact in the eight on the age of empires to
community 11 is the way people laugh just like they'll be
you on JP chats oh I've been give I've been giggling this
whole time okay maybe one day I will come back and have a
what's the word a revenge and with this.
I'll practice off stream.
It is so much fun, though.
I had a lot of fun.
11, 11, 11, 11, 11.
What does it mean?
Like, why, though?
Is it because if you say 11, it's an emote or...
Like a laughing emote?
Revengeance, Metal Gear?
I'll be honest.
I forget that revengeance is not a real word sometimes.
I've been like...
I've been saying Revengeance unironically.
Like, I used to say it ironically, and now I say it
unironically.
But yeah, Tian, this is such a fun game!
I had so much fun.
And I'm going to beat my high score.
I'm going to get to 25.
That's the goal.
And I'm going to screenshot it.
And it won't be edited because you guys know I don't have
the font.
I don't have the font for 25 damn I'm aiming high
Photoshop doesn't exist guys you guys I don't have the font
for 25 it's the laughter taunt in chat yes that's so funny
one one mine mine mine what fantasy meant Would you get
mage, et cetera?
Mmm.
Yeah, this is so much fun.
Thank you for making a fun game.
And it's so cute.
I love hearing Kodana say, I'm a dog.
Um, if I get fantasy outfit, I think merchant is kind of
cute, right?
Like a wanderer.
wandering trade merchant also a mage would be really cute or
like a witch with the big old witch's hat think think a
merchant like breasted here right
oh how do you buy what do you sell it all right I'm gonna
move over to I don't know if you guys noticed but um I have
Corone's bones in my hair.
Give me a second.
I'm going to set up some BGM.
That was a good BGM, but maybe something a little more chill
to let my brain sleep out of my ears.
Actually, no.
I want this one.
Yeah!
You see him?
I'll move this away for a second.
But it kind of is hard to see because of my own hair clip.
I stole Corone's bones.
Her bones are not mine.
Yubi, yubi, as they say.
Corone was the very first YouTuber I watched regularly, so
it was really cool.
see you play this yeah there's so many like cute little
references and everything so fun did she take your Yubis in
return I have no Yubis look can't see my Yubis just floppy
under here just nubs just little this like it's um actually
it's like a lego lego lego hand it's a lego hand so it's
just like one big circle send you bees
well guys i'm going to read donations real quick i didn't i
like i said it's a bit of a shorter stream just wanted
something to have a bit of fun with um of like a little
crazy amount of fun crazy time with rather.
It was fun though.
It was a lot of fun.
Revengeance.
Middle English period 11 11 wait.
1150 to 1500 borrowed from French a furious act of revenge
to use violence to attain peace.
Oh.
Well there you go.
Revengeance is a real word.
Revengeance.
Corona is my... Oh she Thanks for playing this min.
Thank you.
Corone is so cute.
She is so, so cute.
Oh my gosh.
Did you guys see the new the new Kanatan pop-up parade that
was announced or not announced, but like went up for
pre-order recently.
Oh my gosh.
I keep looking at it on Ami Ami because it looks so well
made.
It's so It's so cute
I'll be honest I don't watch her so much But I think her
design is like One of my favorites ever It's just this
cutest ever It's so Such a good design Everything about it
is so perfect I like her mama so much Her mama's art is
always so nice Her scale is crazy good to has so much like
the the the base and everything is so crazy yeah she has
some amazing outfits she does so cute so so cute i like that
i honestly this is gonna sound so weird but i i think i like
the pop-up parade more than her i'm looking at it right now
i think i like it more than her than the scale figure i
think it's maybe because in the scale figure she looks like
a little but in the pop-up parade she looks cuter maybe I
don't know the pop-up is 10 out of 10 sometimes some pop-up
parade figures like I don't mean this like sometimes like
they can like get the faces well this happens with figures
quite often to be honest sometimes the faces can be a little
off but this one is so perfect this one's so good if I could
ever become a pop-up parade figure that would be the coolest
thing ever or just get a figure in general be the coolest
sometimes the pose is too simple mmm I typically like
figures with like cool bases or like there's the shigure ui
one where she's like sitting in the chair so it's not really
a base but like it just adds a little bit of extra something
like I have this one figure where it's just an original
character but she's coming out of a tablet let me see if i
can find a picture of it uh wait what was it called
oh oh i found it i found it i found it oh my gosh Go Google?
By Nishizawa.
It's Nishizawa San.
Oh yes, is there, it's like the artist like, what's the
word?
Self?
Why can't I ever speak?
It's so cute though.
Hold on, I'll show you.
The figure.
Let me, I'm gonna crop it a little bit because it's, oh no,
I don't need to crop it, just kidding save
and i'll be honest like i like this artist i'm not like
diehard fan but i just thought the figure was so cool like
look how cool that is and like she's coming through the
tablet it's so awesome oh my gosh thank you for 50 please
you've already I've been given so many today!
It's awesome, right?
It's really cool.
It's really, really cool.
Um...
I don't have... When I collect figures, it's either
something like this, you know?
Or like a character I super duper love.
But I... I'll get stuff.
There's one figure that I...
I missed out on.
And, uh...
Can I get more?
No!
I appreciate it though, thank you.
There was one figure of like a girl, oh, I found the
picture, oh my gosh.
How am I so good at finding these pictures?
She's in a box.
Like look at this, ah, I should have ordered it.
I'm such a fool.
Look how cool this looks.
Oh, I was gonna say she looks like Ray from Evangelion.
Like isn't it so, ah, it looks so cool.
Like, I really like unique.
kind of figures like this.
It looks so cool.
It's not a cardboard box though.
It is not a cardboard box, no.
And then I ordered one recently.
I don't know when it comes out.
But it's a Yudu Camp figure.
It's actually technically two figures.
Because it's both of them.
And look at this.
Look at this.
the base is grass I can touch grass by touching this figure
wait did you give it another 50 I can't tell if you did
thank you wait I can't tell you did thank you oh thank you
actual it's not actual grass it's fake real grass it's fake
real grass but it's so cute right she made it on her little
bike oh it's such a cute figure it's so cute yeah so i have
that coming when does it release in august in august i will
not and she's drinking corn soup Like, on the figure.
It's just made for me, I think.
It's made for me.
You watched Yudicamp?
Yes!
Yudicamp is one of my favorite anime!
Yes, I love Yudicamp.
Trying to see what else I have ordered.
Well, actually, I don't have that much left.
I think that's the biggest thing I have left.
Yes, the other stuff is like a small free-rin acrylic.
And, um, oh, I got this too.
This is really cute.
And it wasn't so expensive either.
Even though it was, I think it's, they're really small.
Look how cute!
It's just little busts of the free-rin cast!
It's so cute!
little busts of them.
So cute.
The trio.
Female in shambles.
Looks like chest pieces.
I think, to be honest, they might be even that small.
But that's okay.
It's good for like I don't know where to put them yet.
I think I...
Oh my gosh.
Oh stop.
I didn't notice the back.
No, I'm gonna cry.
You guys, look at the back.
No way, I didn't notice it.
But when I ordered it.
What?
That's so cute.
It's so...
I'm tearing up.
It's so sweet.
that's so cute
figures are so expensive now you guys figures are so
expensive not to make like not only just the the shipping
but like the scale figures now like they used to be a
hundred and fifty dollars maybe now they're like 200 $300
it's crazy oh I remember when they were 80 dollars they're
so expensive now it's so so insane the ones I like are not
300 are they more less I can't tell what you mean by that
include shipping and it goes close to 300 luckily I say this
luckily not luckily but like the yen is weak right now so
that's the way i justify some things but
no they're so pricey makes me like um like pop-up parade is
kind of a blessing with how inexpensive it is and the the
range too the variety of characters you can get with pop-up
parade makes it so awesome
but yeah nenderoys used to be 30 i know nenderoys and figmas
used to be so so much less expensive too i saw a hollow
figure going for 1.3k okay to be fair if if it's the pekora
one you're talking about
I think, okay, so I'm pretty sure it's the same brand that
does these kimono like designs and it's actual fabric from
what I understand.
So like I under, I get it.
Like it's actually like, you know, the quality, but it is,
it is still insane.
And it's also one fourth scale.
It's one fourth scale too.
It's not even like one seventh.
It's, it's huge.
It's really, really big.
So,
yeah.
it it's a lot of money but it is quite big and detailed so
i've seen because i i know because i've seen these these
designs multiple times they pop up pretty often on ami ami
so do you have any one-fourth scales no i don't know i
actually i have a bigger kuro neko from oreimo but i don't
know what scale she is but she's she's a little bigger but i
don't think she's one-fourth or maybe
she is maybe she is one fourth oh she is one fourth what do
you know
she's one fourth so mine is one fourth and she's on her
knees so and this pekora is standing up if that gives you
any idea of how big it's going to be.
Like, it's going to be really, really big.
Yoshitoku does the fabric for the Peckle figure.
They've made doll clothes for over 100 years, but the markup
between those anime figures and the traditional dolls is
massively skewed.
God, that makes sense.
I don't know if it's the same manufacturer, or the same,
like, company.
I don't know.
as the other ones.
Let me see.
Pekora.
Uh, Yoshitoku.
Yoshitoku.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, the Pekora one is a lot more expensive than like...
Okay, wait, no, that one's on sale.
Okay, see, here, I'm going to show you some other examples,
ones that I've seen.
Because she's also one-fourth scale.
You have...
I think it's really just their anime figures then, if you're
saying that the other ones are less like their actual dolls
are less expensive because i've seen this this um made
dragon one dragon made uh this one is uh one is it's yeah uh
wait it's it's 157 000 yen so uh amyami says it's about a
thousand dollars and that's on sale so there's that one and
uh let's see I haven't seen this one but I'm oh oh it's so
beautiful oh my god oh my god it's so beautiful wait is this
also one fourth oh yes it is oh this one's about the same
price as the as the pickle one oh my god oh look at her look
at her oh my gosh
She's so beautiful.
Oh, but yeah, they do quite a bit of these.
And they are always this pricey.
Every time I've seen them.
Every time I've seen them, they're this pricey.
I saw the thumbnail and thought you had a collab with
Korone.
A lot of people thought.
Time zones make it hard to catch streams, but we'll support
you regardless.
Also, I want to mention you have a nice voice too.
Take care from Australia.
Dollhala, thank you so much.
I'm sorry that the time zones don't line up, but I
appreciate you dropping by when you can.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
When are we getting a $1,300 made mint figure?
Never.
And there's a Kizna I one too.
It's really, it's...
Their figures are really, really beautiful.
This one's also one-fourth scale.
Oh my gosh.
Their figures are just really pretty.
If you go to Amiami and search...
Oops.
And search...
Yoshitoku?
Yoshitoku, you'll find them.
Any survey from Good Smile, I'm going to be asking for Mid.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no.
Yeah.
Figures are so expensive.
These ones I, I, I know, it might be like a weird copium,
but I kind of get it.
Just because of the fabric.
You think that?
Well, no.
Yeah, because of the fabric and because of the scale, the
size of them.
It is an expensive hobby.
It is.
It's a very expensive hobby.
I think it's also partially why maybe I haven't gotten into
so...
Well, not why I haven't gotten into so many anime.
But, like, part of me is just like, if I get into more
things, I'll want to collect more merch from the things.
You know what I mean?
So it's just like...
Like, last night, right now, Sudugaya is doing free
shipping.
So I was looking at some Metal Gear stuff last night.
would still thank you for the 50 captain thank you so much
thank you thank you thank you um but uh beware warhammer
then um i would say that warhammer is not really my
aesthetic but well you know i like military aesthetic so
it's not completely far off that i got into metal gear Um,
but uh, yeah, I was on Tsutugaya and I was, I was, I was
seeing some blue archive figures that I was like, oh, I, I,
I, no, it's free shipping, but, oh, it's a pain.
In the end, if you're wondering, I did not get anything.
I did not get any of them, so one fourth scale, dang, almost
as tall as you.
Ha!
HAH!
That's a good one!
Ha!
Good one, Fluffy Hoots!
HAH!
SOHilarious.
I'm LM-A-Oing, right now.
I'm LMFA-Oing right now.
I'm raffling right now.
Funniest joke I've ever made.
heard raffle raffle raffle i don't feel safe raffle copter
literally raffle coptering
how do i turn
help help help me help me
That was scary That was freaky That was freaky Okay, I did
say I was going to do Donation reading, so Let me, I'm going
to start with the stream laughs I got the tightest laugh
treatment I'm so happy Glad, I'm glad that I can make that
Real for you I need to get some water Water, water, water.
Today is the 14th.
Starting with Wildest Duck.
I think this was before stream.
Thank you.
I hope we can help a little so you can keep having fun,
Gamba.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Wildest Duck, thank you again.
Congrats on your collab with Corone.
You must have given her so many UBs.
She's so quiet right now.
Can't wait for her to win.
she's done with them.
Yeah, she was just kind of... You know, you heard her the
whole time, right?
You heard her say Yubi-Yubi.
You heard her say Shotgun.
Hmm.
Being a Blue Archive fan is painful.
There's too many characters.
Yeah.
I have only a handful of characters that I really like,
though.
Just a handful.
And that's typically how I am with a lot of things.
Where if there's a ton of or something or if it's an idol
group with a ton of members or something i'll pick like just
a few top five
top five okay um hold on i'm just gonna open up blue archive
haven't logged in today anyway so it's good
um definitely koharu's up there They're in...
Koharu and Cherino are like my top two.
I love them so much.
Koharu and Cherino.
Cherino is so...
I love...
She's so funny.
I love her.
I love Koharu.
Because she's like...
She's actually like peak character design.
She's...
I don't know how they could get so many cute things.
So perfectly balanced and well in one character.
Just so cute.
I think Chettino is underrated.
But she's super duper cute.
She's so silly.
Majang Soul Stream.
I don't even know how to play Majang.
Though I did try to learn from Majang Soul before.
Okay, let's see.
The screen that popped up is Onsen Chettino for me.
Okay, students.
I also really love Toki.
And Hina.
I love Hina.
Toki Wait, so that's Koharu, Hina, Toki Chirino, that's four
I really like Hoshino, but I wouldn't put her into my top
five I really like I really like Midori and Oh my gosh, why
is her sister's name blanking on me?
What's her sister's name?
Momoi!
Yes, oh my gosh.
I was just like, of course, Momoi, Momoi.
I was like, I feel so awful not remembering, or not,
remembering it because, um, because, uh, Momoi Haruko.
I always think of Momoi Haruko every time I think of Momoi.
Which clearly is not enough.
Um, I also really like Arisu.
I like the whole game dev team, to be honest.
Um, gamer cat twins are the best.
They're so cute.
Oh my gosh, the new twins that were released in JP.
Problem solvers, 68 girls are great.
They are.
They are, they are.
I really like Aru too, but I don't have her.
I really love Aru.
Making me want to play.
Sorry.
The Blue Archive talk, everybody.
You can ignore it if you don't add into Blue Archive.
but it's like the only gotcha oh shiroko of course I have to
put in shiroko because she's voiced by my favorite seiyu
ogura yui she's actual tenshi ogura yui pyong pyong kudere
supremacy peace peace I also love how goofy shiroko is she's
so fun because she's she's she like is kudere but she's So,
so silly at the same time.
You're gonna love the dress Aru.
Thoughts on Wakamo?
I really like Wakamo, but I don't have her.
So I don't know much about her.
Like, well, I know, you know, I know a little, but like, you
know what I mean.
And, um, I also really like Saki.
I like the Rabbit Squad a lot because they're really cute.
Um, even though I only have Mo.
I only have...
Oh wait, no, I have swimsuit, Miu.
And...
Wait, I have one more too.
Who is it?
Wait, do I?
Oh, meyako.
Swimsuit, meyako.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got Wakamo swimsuit, but not regular Wakamo.
I don't have either.
I don't have that many characters, to be honest.
That's so sad.
I don't have that many characters.
luck in this game is so garble.
Yeah.
But out of Rabbit Squad, I like Saki the most.
I really like her helmet.
Yes, yes.
Yes.
Need to pull on stream for streamer luck.
We'll see.
I only have 9,000 jemmies.
So I'm not doing any pulling at the moment.
I am waiting.
Who is next?
Who?
What is...
Who is next?
New twins are called Hikari and Nozumi?
After the Shin... As soon as you said that, I knew the
Shin-Kansen!
Oh no, that makes me like them even more!
Wait, Railgun collab is next?
Oh!
I never got Miku, so...
Okay.
We'll save for Railgun.
Swimsuit Hina just came up on my screen.
Okay.
Where was I?
Rico, thank you.
Rico, thank you again.
Alex, thank you.
Go mint nassai.
Kayvarn, thank you.
Pirate six.
Oh.
Six, thank you.
Cheer on chat, thank you.
The rock boss, thank you.
Thank you for the revengeance definition.
Now we know it's a real word.
Lutus, thank you.
So more dono, more figures.
No!
Oh my gosh, thank you for the pink dono.
No, no, no, no.
I have just the...
Well, the Yudokamp 1 is really expensive, so I have been
holding off on pre-ordering anything else.
I was like, I will.
I am pacing...
Pacing myself.
Oh, there it is.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you guys for all this stream.
Wow.
Thank you.
And.
Super chats.
Oh my gosh, guys.
We're almost to 180,000.
And then next 190.
And then maybe.
200 that'd be kind of crazy that'd be a little wacky if that
happened are you planning anything for 200k whoa I I didn't
um I didn't well I don't know I are going to get there so
fast.
But I didn't expect to get this far this fast.
So I guess I will plan something for 200k.
I will plan something.
I already have some ideas.
yes, yes, yes.
And some of them, if I implement them, might take a little
bit longer.
So I have some time, which is good.
Oh my god.
The 50, thank you.
Okie dokie.
As for your super chats.
Chiliacs, thank you.
Murphy, hot dog.
Raymac, hot dog.
AKS TF2, hot dog.
Seymour, thank you.
We're all ready to hear Yubi Yubi multiple times.
Star Creator, thank you.
Spank, hot dog.
Clarence, friend, thank you.
Today's my birthday.
I wanted to share some with my kami osi ghost made i have
pistachio cake and fancy cookies feel free to possess me and
eat some i will after stream if you feel a chill i'm an
older lady now i can't eat as many cookies as i used to
don't worry i will eat some for you i'll have just a nibble
happy birthday claret happy birthday to you happy birthday
to you happy birthday to you Happy birthday, dear Claret
F-F-F-H-H-H-H-H-H-H-E-B-Birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
I wanted to say, even though I don't have much knowledge or
understand much of anything you like, such as blue archive
or your feet fetishes, I do like your energy and your
passion for your hobbies.
Thanks for always being you for who you are.
Where did the feet thing come from?
No, it's so funny.
I was looking at Little Witch Nobita stuff earlier.
And there was this one phone stand.
With her feet out so much.
But I was like...
I...
Her toes looked like fingers.
It was like feet!
I made me feel...
I didn't really like it.
Like, I was like, oh my gosh.
I feel like I can smell this picture, but not in a good way.
Nobita has some interesting merch in Twitter posts.
Yes, they do.
If you...
I'm not going to put up the picture because something about
it makes me uncomfortable.
I don't know what it is.
Don't feet.
I'm not I'm not I'm not feet shaming I get it like I get it
if you're in defeat I get it but it's just not my thing it's
just not my thing it really looks like monkey toes I that's
what I'm saying
would you be interested in joining my new maid cafe it's
called super cute awesome maids aka cafe scam whoa oh my
gosh and you're all about them I can tell you're like a scam
I'm Kamioshi, you're just scam.
Wow.
Super cute, awesome maids.
Hmm.
I like it.
Got my scam.
SCAM.
Sorry.
Is it not scam?
Is it SCAM?
Sorry.
Prospect the hustle.
It sounds so legit.
I mean, I'm already in a maid cafe right now, as you can
see.
But I will consider.
Will there be a competitor called F-R-A-U-D?
Mmm.
Yeah, I mean, we can't have a monopoly here, right?
There could be S-H-A-M.
Cafe Sham.
Anyway, they are eating Mike Tyson's ass.
Yubi, yubi, thank you.
Minty Fresh Kyle, thank you.
Mint, if you hate us, don't say anything.
Oh, wait.
Something.
Anything.
Wait.
If you don't...
Wait, if you hate us...
Don't say anything.
Oh, I mixed it up.
I thought you meant, I thought you meant if you like us, say
anything.
Wait, if you hate us, say, wait.
Huh?
I thought if you don't hate us, say anything.
Quit your crying, quit your crying.
I don't want to see...
I don't want to see any more of these two.
Cheers!
Quit your crying!
Quit your crying.
Ego Josu.
Yeah?
What about it?
Quit your crying.
This is the real world.
This is what you will hear on a daily basis.
Someone will walk up to you on the street and they'll say,
Hey, I hate you.
That's just the reality of things.
You gotta be tough.
You gotta be a tough cookie out there.
It's true.
That's messed up.
That's just how life is, man.
Here to gauge your interest in my venture, the freaking
rad...
Oh!
Awesome, ultra delicious cafe.
F-R-A-U-D for short!
Competition.
Oh my gosh, I'm getting too many offers, you guys.
Please, please, please respect my boundaries.
Send it to my email.
Send it to my manager, aka me.
Why do you make us cry?
Stop telling me what to do, VTuber.
Fine.
I won't tell you twice.
Pre-order bonus, thank you!
For the 10, thank you so much!
Mint, get a manager.
Okay, but you make it sound so easy!
You make it sound so easy!
Like... like...
How does one just acquire a manager?
I have to find someone...
I don't know anybody.
Second of all, I have to find someone that's not gonna steal
all my information and run away like a Looney Tunes villain,
okay?
The afterlife is hard, okay?
Ask Mr. Mayan.
Just call Mr. Mayan.
Why is...
The manager's store.
I'm gonna go to a vending machine.
Manager vending machine.
Minty Fresh Kyle, thank you!
Paperbacks, thank you!
Gato Ruffin, thank you!
Hmm?
It's...
I feel disturbance in the floors.
Minty Fresh Kyle, thank you!
Minty Fresh Kyle, thank you again!
YouTube GPT Chatbot, version 1.51, thank you!
Glor- Koro-san is the greatest VTuber of all time.
All glory to the dog god.
The chatbots are out of hand.
YouTube GPT chatbot version 1.51.
I wonder what he'll say in version 1.52.
Dog I am.
Wait, are you a chatbot or are you a dog?
Who gave this dog?
Who gave this dog a keyboard?
Thank you, thank you.
um may i interest you in super chill amazing managers god i
wish finally managed to get to stream a lot of streams
overlap with work unfortunately compared to years ago oh no
but thank you for dropping by when you can this min girl
seems like a cute happy awesome really awesome totally
awesome nerd charlotte
that's quite the praise on the internet nobody knows you
were a dog eating Mike Tyson's butt thank you Hyman I'm
excited to watch that I hope your day is going well
actually it's so funny a friend of mine was just like what's
up with that eating Mike Tyson's butt guy why does everyone
always say legend legend every time he comes up and so I
actually I showed them, I showed them the clip of Korone
saying your name and her just going, no!
So I watched it again recently.
So, yeah.
Fancy seeing you, fancy seeing you.
Thanks for dropping by so often.
Evans Kazoo covers, thank you.
too?
Not enough chief.
Second soul, thank you.
Did you play Death Must Die?
Matara liked it a lot.
I have not.
Also, thank you.
I'm listening while halfway through a six to seven mile walk
and regretting it.
Regretting the stream or regretting the walk.
Which one?
Which one are you regretting?
Hey, Mint, you seem super into Metal Gear.
We all know the real reason to play MGS though.
For shipping!
Who's your favorite pair and who's your favorite rare pair?
Favorite pair is Big Boss and Ocelot.
Rare pair.
Rare pair Rare pair Rare pair Rare pair Rare pair
Dirty pair Rare pair Rare pair Rare pair
Hmm.
Rare pair.
Miller Naomi.
No.
They don't even know each other.
Rare pair.
Oh.
Obviously, vamp and Naomi.
Um, uh, Vamp and Naomi.
Great couple.
My favorite rare pair.
Ew.
Yuck.
I was choked on my drink.
Vamp and Riot and you mean.
What are you talking about?
It's the best rare pair.
Um, Riko, thank you!
I'm glad you're enjoying your Hell Divers training.
Actually, um, Mataro is trying to organize a Hell Divers
collab.
Because I've been wanting to play it.
So yeah, good training.
I know that I will be so useful.
Oh, actually, I should play MGS 5 again.
So for actual training.
Hey, MF, it's Piccolo again.
Dirty pair of what?
Dirty pair of socks.
Wash your socks, everybody.
Minsky First Kyle, thank you.
Minsky First Kyle, thank you again.
Yukurishtay, didn't it?
Bravery Duck, thank you.
This game really makes you feel like Toho.
Oh, I felt the Toho.
Murphy, Dog.
Thank you.
Destiny 13777, thank you.
Stephen Tonch, thank you.
Damian Roth, thank you.
George Scannell, thank you.
Minty Fresh Kyle Cockroach Thank you, I think Bubby Cork,
thank you Shinsular, thank you Crusher Match, thank you
Lemon seems to be my lucky number Trup, thank you I'm Die,
thank you forever That was one of the achievements I got
Murphy, thank you Dogstrings, thank you DJ Zig, thank you
Minty Fresh Kyle, thank you Fake Neat, thank you Kool-Aid
Man, thank you Mr. Uncle Mode, thank you.
Rico, thank you.
Spank, thank you.
Wireson, thank you.
I just realized the time.
You guys, I gotta put it together.
My desk.
I mean, my furniture.
So let's say I'm happy to see you back again.
I've loved every stream.
I don't talk much in chat, but every stream has been so much
fun.
Aww, thank you.
Happy to be back.
Have a lot of fun every day, so thank you guys.
That's such an awesome name.
It sucks you have to be the second one, though.
Shelf-building stream.
Dog strings, thank you.
Jolly Ram Rancher, thank you.
Inane, thank you.
Leah D, thank you.
X21, thank you.
95.
Intract.
Did I say that right?
Thank you.
Slimekin, thank you.
Back decor, thank you.
Reynard, thank you.
Ria, thank you.
Nushi, sushi, thank you.
Ice dream, thank you.
Gato Refin, thank you.
Gato Refin, thank you again.
Leah D, thank you.
Varylant, thank you.
Far the killer, thank you.
Star creator, thank you.
Lima, Lima, thank you.
Genos.
Hello, connoisseur, thank you.
Sorry, I was making sure I said your, did I say your name
right?
I hope so.
And it meant if you don't hate us, don't say, Wait, if you
don't hate us...
Wait, oh no!
Um...
Flash...
Message.
You're welcome.
Speaking of figures, I recently got my Miku 15th anniversary
shortcake figure.
It's so cute.
Wait, I don't know if I've seen that one before.
Oh, oh.
Oh my god, it's beautiful.
Oh my gosh, it's beautiful.
It's so pretty.
Oh my god, the base is a plate.
What scale is she?
Oh my god, the price on it.
Wait, the price.
What scale is she?
One seventh.
Sheesh.
She is so cute.
Oh my gosh.
The macaron too is so... Everything is so cute.
Minto-chan-kyo-mo-kawaii.
Yeah, you guys, I said it.
It means I don't hate you guys.
Stop crying.
I should unprivate, though.
I don't think I had the flash message on my...
You know, I had a tongue twister video.
I should unprivate.
it it's kind of cringe here like hearing me from so long ago
she hates us
love seeing different games hope you keep having a lot of
fun with them replay tokyo jungle after you mention it i
should play tokyo jungle should i should i should i could
play whatever i want that's the craziest that's the craziest
thing is if there's something i want to play comes out i
could play it i could play whatever i want whatever actually
that's a lie there are some things that i will stay away
from that i kind of want to play but i won't because i'm
scared of nintendo like if it's like a pokemon mod i won't i
probably won't play it because i've seen that a lot of
channels have been getting struck.
Choo!
I've heard other VTuber complaining that there's actually
too little MGS fanfiction.
Is this true?
I don't read fanfiction.
But I have talked about this with a friend where we were
like...
We were like...
When the Master Collection comes out, maybe all the girlies
will be like, Yes, this is it.
This is the game.
This is the series.
And there will be so much more Dojin.
But, unfortunately, it hasn't, it hasn't, at least from what
I've noticed, it hasn't changed much.
So, like, I went to Comic-Cit last year.
I went to Winter Comic-Cit.
And, um, there was only a few tables with MGS Dogein.
And they were all, they were all, like, from five, so it was
a little disappointing.
So sad, so sad, so sad.
Um, limo limo, thank you!
Thank you for all the gifted donors, or gifted memberships.
I really appreciate it!
Dog strings, thank you!
Dalhalla, thank you!
Fluffy hoods, thank you!
Galactic core, thank you!
Greetings from Germany!
What time is it?
Guten...
I don't know.
Wait, it's...
It's really late there.
Time in Germany.
1 a.m.
in Germany.
Good night.
Yes.
Oh, gosh.
Don't let her hear me say this.
Don't let her hear me say it.
Alf Wiederschen.
She's gonna come for me, you guys.
She's gonna come for me.
Alf, Wieders...
Alf...
Hold on, someone put it.
Alf, Alf, Alf, Alf...
Where'd it go?
Alf...
Wait, where'd it go?
Alf Someone Someone broke it apart Where'd it go?
Oh, Alf flash Stop, stop, stop Alf Alf Alf Alf Alf Alf Alf
Fythosen Alf Fythosen
Yeah Yeah
Anyway.
Um, yeah, that means you should go to bed.
Galactic Core, thank you.
FulfiHoods, thank you.
Katrina Dungo, thank you.
Hi, Minty.
No time, no super chat.
You look gorgeous as ever.
Ah.
Thank you.
Rico, thank you.
Inane, thank you.
Virulent, thank you.
Refresh.
Also, Pirate.
Six, oh, six, thank you.
I read your donut.
but I didn't thank you.
Thank you so much.
Auf Wienerschwitzel!
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Your German is cute, greeting.
Greetings from another German wisp.
Is that why I can't say your name right?
Let me see you later.
Yeah, I'm telling you to go to sleep.
I'm telling you to go to sleep!
Oh wait, where did I leave off on?
Uh-oh.
Oh, oh, oh, here we go.
Um...
Rodrigo, thank you!
What a great way to spend my cozy Sunday, relaxing with Mint
and Korone.
Thanks for another fun stream.
Thank you!
Resting... Resting... Resting... Resting...
Resting!
Thank you!
I think I may have stolen some of your luck.
I was playing a similar game, Kill the Crows, while
listening, and got six unlocks in ten minutes.
Gomen Nassai.
That's okay.
I forgive you.
Actually, I don't forgive you.
I don't forgive you.
I'm going to haunt you.
I'm going to haunt you until you give me my luck back.
That was weird.
What was happening?
Oh, customer Johnson, thank you.
Wow, this dog, hi dog.
Thank you.
You got it.
You got some competition up in here.
I'm just saying.
With just, you know.
Potware.
Thank you.
Ego Jozu.
Paki Donut.
Thank you.
Magish.
You can hate me any day.
Follow my baby.
Thank you.
Take up.
Take up Nyanyan.
Thank you.
Nyan.
No, stop crying.
Nixitava.
Thank you.
Niels Wilder.
Sionios, thank you.
Just scam, thank you.
Karma strikes, thank you.
Rico, thank you.
Katrina dungo, thank you.
It's a bow, bow world out there.
So true.
Zazamos, thank you.
Hot dog, where do I sign up for a haunting?
You know, that's the fun part about it.
Just by being here, you sign up.
come and possess you a little bit.
A little.
When you least expect a possession, it will arrive.
Piccolo, thank you.
Hakunon Matara, thank you.
Or Hakunon, Hakunon Matara.
I guess that makes more sense, right?
David Titanium Pepe, dog.
Thank you.
Gliss, thank you.
Super G, thank you.
Is Johnny and bathroom a rare pair since he hardly makes it
actually i do like johnny and maryl so maybe that's like a
it's like a it's like a no oh my gosh you guys my favorite
my favorite rare pair is riding and rose how could i forget
them the most powerful couple in the world they are my
favorite toxic I live for Ryden and Rose drama.
I love it so much.
It's so fun.
They're such a great...
It's my favorite telenovela ever.
Sketch, welcome to Membusha.
Thank you.
Egotistical woman.
Does that count as a rare pair?
Maybe because I don't think many people ship them.
I don't think many people ship them.
What did I enter to?
I'm just reading Donos.
We have bullets, thank you.
Fukuro-chana, thank you.
Karateka, thank you.
Please don't possess or haunt me while I'm on the toilet.
That would be embarrassing for me.
Thank you.
I don't want to do that.
So I think you're safe.
Red Ranger, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Oh no, I'm possessed!
Oh no, my $10 turning into figurine funds!
No!
Oh my gosh, no!
Stoppy doodle!
Where was I?
Lilia, Seraphina, thank you!
I have no idea how much joy you bring me and everyone's
seeing you, laugh, smile, being yourself every time you
stream thank you thank you so nice of you thank you flue
deli is gaming definitely think i said that wrong but thank
you so much alf no no not the not this not the schnitzel i'm
truck thank you go to sleep neil's water thank you how can
we sleep when our kami oh she is streaming No!
I will try and do...
Try and do...
Uh...
EU-friendly time this week.
The salt work on goes...
Yes!
Ouch!
Stop!
Why would you send that?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Stop it.
Why would you do that?
I think I should go to sleep.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to yell.
Um...
Ninja Tim, thank you!
Greetings from Austria, too.
Good to knock!
Lenguini-Hudini, made Inugami Phantom.
Nope.
Why?
Thank you.
Nicole, thank you!
Rodrigo, thank you!
Rico, hot dog!
Kaito, thank you!
Nicole, I don't know why I get this feeling, but like, are
you my girlfriend?
Did I Possess someone And ask you out I don't know Stop!
Stop sending me salt Stop it, stop it That's why I'm not
salty at all Because I'm not salty at all Because it will
literally kill me, you guys
I think someone I possessed Asked you out, Nicole I don't
know why I feel like that But anyway Um Rico hot dog!
Kaito, the ramen bandit, thank you!
I started practicing Otake dance movements, and as a
31-year-old dude, I'm impressed how others go at it.
Please be careful, because I can actually...
Like, at least...
At least...
At least stretch properly, because you can really hurt your
back.
Oh my gosh, the salts!
Customer Johnson, thank you!
Resting Glitch Face, thank you!
Oh, sauce!
Wire Sun, ooh!
Paperbacks, ooh!
Pocky Donut, ooh!
Kenja!
Baby Paladin, oh, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Amelia Zhang, oh, yeah, like a snail, oh, wow, the suck, oh,
wrong for rabbit, oh.
Have you noticed a change in behavior?
Do Metal Gear and Idol goods arrive that you don't remember
ordering?
You may have been possessed by Made Mint Phantom.
Don't complain, you're a lucky person.
You guys are literally killing me.
Fake neat.
Yuki Baskerville.
What about pepper?
No, that's okay.
Thanks, Dingus-Kan.
Take up Nyan-Yan.
Renane.
Brayback.
Why are you guys doing this to me?
I'm turning off donuts right now.
Turn off.
I understand the implications of this action.
Perfect.
Okay, now.
refresh refresh um ashen sloth sketch the cartoon guy the
podcast is a hoot if you're still thinking of haunting a
grocery store on the side let me tell you working retail as
hell i know i have done it i have done it um i don't know
quite yet Part of me is just like Things are stressful and I
just want to Go back to having a normal job So I don't have
to think about it But You know Oh Literally 1984 Totally
assaulted She hates us Stop you're crying Stop you're crying
Vukuro Pandification Thank you Does it work with kosher or
fortified salt?
I think it's just any salt.
What is a fortified salt?
Anyway.
Murphy game over.
That's it, everybody.
Go home.
Spank, thanks for the 20 gifted.
Nebula, thank you for the gifted.
I'm gonna go, oh my gosh.
I suddenly got super hungry.
So I'm gonna go eat.
I'm gonna go have dinner And I suggest the same For you guys
Also I see you in the stream labs Gaya and Chironcha I see
you both I see you I see you I see you I see you I see you
Otsumita Everybody I am just gonna leave Because I'm
Starting to get shaky hungry I'm hungry hungry.
Let's have a good meal.
Atumito.
Atumito, atumito, atumito, atumito.
Bye bye.
Thank you guys.
Thank you for another fun stream.
So you guys, not tomorrow because tomorrow is, well, I will
see you on the podcast if you listen.
Please listen.
Bye bye.
Thank you guys.
Thank you so much as always.
I